So now you've seen that you can encode four things
in bits. You can encode any number, we just need more
bits. So if we have more bits, we can encode
more different things. So, here I've got four bits. That means
I have four yes, no choices. And I can encode
sixteen different numbers. And the reason for that is because 2
to the 4 is 16. Every time I add one
more bit, I double the number of things. Because I have
one more yes, no question. So for just this part
of the graph, I had eight things, I had three bits.
I could distinguish between the numbers zero through seven. Adding one
more bit, doubles the number of things I can distinguish. So
that's a way to measure information. And once we can distinguish
any number of things. Well, we can send any kind of
data we want. Anything that's discreet, we can turn into a
number. So we could turn letters into numbers. If we have
a long string, we could have a sequence of numbers, which
we can turn into one really big number. So, once we can
send bits, we can send anything we want. So that's what
bandwidth is. It's a measure of the amount of information that we
can send, and we're measuring the number of bits. Each bit
is one yes or no decision. In computing, we usually think of
that as either a 0 or 1. So that long stream of
0's and 1's is the information we're sending. And it could be
encoding a string of text like a dozen of web
page. It could be encoding an image, it could be
encoding a number. And to measure our bandwidth, we need
to know how many bits can we send per second.